[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people we have neither for you today
because it's us who are being
interviewed the tables have turned we
have comedian actor karen dunbar talking
to us you're here from the bbc tell
everybody a little bit of how this
happened and what we're doing here i'll
show you thanks guys and i'm making a
program for bbc about
cancer culture comedy walkness what we
can say what we can't say now and why
can we not say things and i thought you
two guys would be the very people to ask
you're in the right place far away cool
so firstly tell me start with you
francis how did you get into comedy uh i
got into comedy uh in the same way that
everyone gets into comedy because nobody
when they get into comedy is in a good
place do you know what i mean nobody
goes you know what i'm nailing life
let's go into a basement of a pub and
tell jokes to three disinterested
strangers and comedians are a bunch of
uh narcissists so i was a teacher i
wasn't very happy with where i was i've
always loved comedy i've always been
very passionate a fan of chris rock bill
hicks that type of comedian and that's
what i wanted to do and that's what my
dream was to you know to write comedy
about the state of the world talking
about what's happening why it's
happening and that's how i started on my
comedy journey really
i can identify
and uh constantin
yourself well uh it's interesting
francis says that for me i i was also
kind i was just a little bit bored of my
job really more than anything but also
the people that i always thought of as
comedians were really as i now realize
they were more satirists than comedians
they were people who were uh talking
about the political events and what was
happening in society people like george
carlin and bill hicks they weren't
necessarily pumping out a gag every two
seconds they were people who had
something to say and i naively thought
that's what comedy is now
so i went in thinking that that's what
the world is and of course you very
quickly find out that that isn't how it
is uh and um you know i i worked quite
hard i i did my own show in edinburgh
about free speech uh after a contract
that i was involved which we may go on
to talk about um
and uh then you know sort of halfway
through that process we started the show
to explore some of the things that we
started to see in the world
and that's been my journey through
through the comedy and sort of uh this
this part of of the industry if you like
so since starting comedy what have you
seen about how it's changed what
give me an example if you can about what
you could have said at the start of your
journey and what you feel that you've
had to
put to the side now or not put to the
side right so a good example of this is
uh my first comedy gig was in august the
first uh 2009 and back then it was a
very very different landscape
comedically if you think who the biggest
comedian at that time was particularly
in britain it was frankie boyle saying
the most outrageous offensive jokes
possible and back then on the london
open mic circuit which is where i
started there was this car there was
this culture of saying her horrific
offensive things
in order to be seen to be edgy to be
shocking to get a shock laugh because a
lot of people wanted to be like frankie
ball not everybody there was another
group of people who wanted to be like
stuart lee but very much there was that
frankie boyle jim jeffries-esque
comedian
and more and more you saw that
that type of comedy became less
prevalent on tv it became less common
the what you could discuss on tv the
type of jokes that were being broadcast
on tv became more more and more and more
how can i put this clean the teeth were
being removed from it to what you see
now on mock the week there's no
resemblance to what was on mock the week
in 2009
you just couldn't get away with a lot of
the jokes that happened i mean i'll give
you an example which is for instance
on mock the week i remember frankie ball
making a joke about jordan's disabled
son harvey and basically the premise of
the joke was that the reason she was
going out with this cage fighter is
because he was the only person who could
prevent harvey from then going and
committing unspeakable acts against
jordan now i didn't particularly like
that joke i don't find that joke funny
but that's an example of you could say
an outrageously transgressive joke on tv
and now you just wouldn't be able to say
that in fact there's lots of jokes now
that you would have got away with even
three or four years ago that simply
won't happen a good example of this is
you will never see or very rarely see
a comedian criticize
labor or jeremy corbyn there's very very
few why well when i did it with the
reason is that when i did it i remember
i had a great one of my favorite
routines i ever wrote about the labour
party and jeremy corbyn around brexit
and uh it was very funny and a lot of
people would find it funny but there was
always a hiss
when you did it it was like
just uh it's a bit it's a bit of a long
one um it's a bit of a long routine but
basically i was calling out jeremy
corbyn for not saying what he thought
about brexit being inconsistent right
because we know he probably voted leave
and then he pretended anyway uh but but
there was a big hiss
that was always there no matter how
funny the rest of the audience were
finding and i think somehow people got
into this idea in the head that
it's not okay to make fun of different
parts of the political spectrum there's
only one target that's allowed now which
i find very odd but i'll give you an
example coming back to your earlier
question about what you can and can't
say because
you know you again i think this is this
will be relevant to the conversation
because i remember the first time we had
a guest on our show that we didn't know
was andrew doyle he's a comedian he's a
gay guy and we're very good friends with
andrew and he came in and i was doing my
research on my phone as he's coming in
and i said to france i didn't know he
was gay and francis looked at me with a
twinkle in his eye and went don't agree
with it either right
a joke among friends who understand that
it's not meant seriously irony right
something we all recognize as part of
the normal process of human connection
if you did that in public as i've just
done but you did it on mainstream
television you'd be destroyed because no
one wants to no one wants to give you
the benefit of the doubt that maybe you
were being friendly and joking as
opposed to you seriously meant some sort
of discriminatory point do you know what
i mean and what does destroyed mean now
so destroyed and you've got a fantastic
poster up there saying cancel culture is
a myth so as cancel the same as
destroyed
yeah to me what cancel culture means is
that so for instance you can lose your
tv shows you will become uh you you will
be dog piled which means on twitter lots
of people then quote tweet you demand
that you know that you lose your agent
that you lose your shows that you lose
you know your career
you know we there's there's a comedian
who's a circuit community he's doing
very well on the circuit he's a very
funny guy
he made a joke on a podcast
and he lost his book deal as a result
yeah yeah yeah and it wasn't even that
it wasn't even a like a and some kind of
evil joke either yeah and it's it's
partly comedy but when you know when we
talk i know this is about comedy and i
understand that but it sounds very kind
of distant from the lives of normal
people but i can give you other examples
there was a guy who posted a billy
connolly routine about religion on his
facebook yep and he got sacked from his
job and actually gets sacked yeah wow
for for jokes from a dvd that they
[ __ ] sell in asda yeah
[Laughter]
that's funny yeah
do you know what i mean i mean
and on and on it goes we've had plenty
of people on this show who've who've you
know we had a guy called nick buckley on
the show he ran a charity for inner city
kids in manchester who were struggling
who were coming from single-parent
households who needed a bit of help to
get them to succeed in life right and he
ran that for 20 years i think he got an
mbe uh he was recognized for his
achievements during the blm protest last
year he had a different opinion of that
particular movement he said it he got
fired from his own charity
he got fired from his own charity that
he started 20 years ago right that's
what we're talking about to me when when
comedians like us or people in the
public eye and anyway start talking
about cancer culture even i cringe
slightly because i think these are
people who've got a platform they've got
you know a great job blah blah blah blah
blah but there's a lot of ordinary
people who get cancelled for things and
they don't have a platform on youtube to
talk about it and to be like this is
wrong you know what does it do to us to
live under that threat especially in
comedy well i tell you what it does to
us it's
what it does it means you self-censor
your thoughts but it also means that you
self-censor when it comes to writing we
had david badila on the show a couple of
months ago the most lefty liberal
comedian and even he said
that he senses himself when he starts to
write jokes so what that means is that
you sanitize the art form to me what
great comedy is is when you think to
yourself i can't believe they said that
and if you think about the great
comedians that you probably fell in love
with the billy collins you know the
richard pryor's they were all saying
these shocking things but we need that
as a society we need the mirror to be
held up to us and if we say oh that is
hate speech you cannot say that then
you're destroying the art form and also
as well you are destroying the
comedian's ability to hold up and
challenge
some of the things in our society which
is simply wrong
but what do we say to the people and i'm
including myself in this who have
potentially suffered at the hands of
huge big comedy pieces
well-known
things that have been taken and then
used as racist laws homophobic slurs
how do we like what
uh
good yes
i don't know
um
i kind of think is anything specific and
it may come to me
but
that if we
continue to laugh and mock certain
minorities then that goes into the ether
and gives
people uh permission to laugh and treat
minorities as less than but this is why
i ask you the question of an example
because
there's that's a and this is with all
full respect to you that's a very loaded
question because you've said
continue to mock people and and yeah you
know like i'd need an example of that
because i i'm not turning on the bbc at
the moment and going oh there's this
comedian attacking a group of people
based on their race are you seeing that
i don't remember in the time i've lived
in this country which is since 1995 i
don't ever remember seeing that right
someone going after gay people or black
people or jewish people or whatever
on that basis so you'd have to give me
an example i think
okay well i'm a bit scrambling here a
bit but i'm way back into like people
like bernard manning and jim davidson
and how derogatory they were towards
ethnic minorities people of color
women
does that know give
people permission to
ridicule well if we're talking about
bernard manning
i'm with you yeah do you know what i
mean like i i wasn't you know i wasn't
one of these people in 1997 he was going
political correctness
none of us here uh about that at all
it'd be a weird position for a 14 year
old yeah exactly exactly i mean i was
the sort of 14 year old that would have
been political but you know what i mean
so
it's about where the line is karen isn't
it it's about whether the line of what
you should and shouldn't do and what is
your angle and what you're coming from
if someone is just making fun of
ethnic minorities because of ethnic
minorities that's one thing but the
example i would give you is i would talk
on stage doing stand-up before the great
plague about people being racist to me
in this country right and
i i would turn the joke on the racists
obviously as you would yeah um
and he was always the ethnic minorities
in the audience who would laugh and it
was always the guilty white people who'd
look around
at the nearest black person or brown
person yeah just to check that it was
okay for them to laugh yeah but did they
then internalize that shame and then go
and take it
with more fuel underneath it towards
ethnic minorities or however they're
biased against them would you defend ben
manning's right to do his comedy today
if he was still with us god rest his
soul
would i defend his right to do comedy
i think
this is this is a very good question
where you think about it and you go
to be honest with you i don't like his
comedy i don't agree with it i i find it
abhorrent i find it racist
should he be allowed to perform his
comedy in a free society fortunately he
should
why unfortunately well unfortunately
because
i don't like it i don't like it i don't
find it pleasant i don't find it
i i find it offensive to me
so that's a personal preference as
opposed to it being dangerous that you
believe it's dangerous for him to have
freedom of speech yes i believe there's
people in the so we talk i think we give
comedians far more power than they
actually have
this idea that somebody is going to tell
a joke and then it's going to change the
way people think i i don't believe
comedy has that power i i was listening
to an interview with bill burr where he
said if it did have that power it would
have been banned by now and i'm fully
with him on that
totally ugly and i think that actually
if we're talking about people with power
there's people like pretty patel
bringing in a whole load of laws that
coming in you know making it legal for
journalists to embarrass the government
up to 14 years i mean
those are the people we need to worry
about not some you know comedian with
unpleasant and obnoxious views playing
to half empty theaters in a seaside town
and also you've got to remember as well
society itself has changed since two
right so even if bernard manning was to
come back from the grave now i don't
imagine there'd be much of an audience
for him comedy is kind of self-selective
you don't need rules about it all you
need is to let the audience choose who
they want to go and see yeah one of the
guys you interviewed pardon my memories
yeah help me and i just watched it
recently about comedy and he said if you
want to do anything if you don't like my
comedy
the thing to do is do nothing
don't laugh
say no
because if the enough of the audience is
not laughing guarantee the comedian will
change the joke right yeah exactly
exactly but also you know it's it's also
about interpretations isn't it it's
about
whether you are giving the comedian the
benefit of the doubt that they're
probably not coming from an evil place
they're coming from a place of trying to
make you laugh and i always found it
very weird because i used to have a
routine that i loved about how we need a
special olympics for white people
right and it was based on the idea that
white people don't seem to do as well at
the olympics in many events as non-white
people right it's just a fact and it was
a joke in if you were to look at it from
the comedy thing of like it's punching
up at the powerful white people and yet
most people would get uncomfortable and
i had to build in about 50 different
yeah other jokes just to go no no no
guys this is not me being racist i'm
just making a joke about something we
all know is true right but as as society
changed over the last five years more
and more people were uncomfortable even
at the idea of race being discussed more
and more uh you know francis and i
talked about this how uh you know the
differences between men and women
used to be a staple of comedy right uh
and it was so so much a staple of comedy
was actually kind of hack yes not even
kind it was ultra hack yeah now you can
go on stage at a comedy gig and go guys
how many genders are there
right and the next one what's a woman
yeah yeah i recently uh interviewed
lgbtqi plus elders they're all over 50
and i've got to say so my mind was open
because
sometimes i come from a place of
what does it does it matter does it
matter i mean am i even asking that
behind you know my hand doesn't doesn't
matter because
to even question
loud new feels like a huge risk
never mind make a statement
so what do you see in terms of
i'll come back to the shift you spoke
about between
like in the last 10 years
is any of the
comedy that's coming out today that's
been sanitized does it make you laugh
does it still work as comedy does it
still serve its purpose i mean though i
watched bill bur uh bo burnham's
netflix special now was that the
funniest special i ever saw not really
no but it was very very interesting what
he was doing playing with the form it
was sort of comedy as art but look there
are people who
manage to be very transgressive and
tackle these topics and do very well out
of it the prime example of that is
someone like bill burr there's also dave
chappelle who does it very very well
another comedy hero of mine but these
people are already very powerful they
already have huge audiences
you know for everybody else and for
people who are wanting to break through
get into the clubs do that type of
material it's almost impossible if you
want to get on tv
let's say you're a comedian who's
written this incredible bit that's very
gender critical are you going to get on
mock the week doing that yeah i mean
yeah
that that would have happened 10 years
ago yeah
yeah absolutely so why why is it shifted
like this it shifted for me because
there's a very very vocal minority of
people
who complain
get angry
so for instance when we got signed to
our comedy agent there was a group of
comedians
who tried to organize a group to get us
cancelled from our asia seriously but
but i think i think there's a there's i
mean we could talk about this for many
hours because one of the things we've
explored on trigonometry our show is
that this isn't just about comedy it's
much more deep than that but if we stick
to the comedy i mean look let's just
let's just name the culprits shall we
nika burns the the organizer and founder
of the edinburgh festival right she said
in 2018 that she looks forward to a new
era of woe comedy now for people who
don't know the edinburgh festival is
essentially the be on be all and end-all
in british comedy if you don't go to the
edinburgh festival if you don't have a
successful show there if you don't do
well if you don't get seen by the right
people if you don't get win the awards
you're not going to progress you're not
going to get on tv now if the person
running that says we need woke comedy
well what's what chance does anyone who
is not that have and you know when i
look
i i want to make it very clear to
anybody watching and to you yourself
francis and i are delighted with where
we are in our lives there is no
bitterness or any complaint or any oh i
didn't get this opportunity i don't care
we're very happy with how our lives have
been i'm fine
yeah i'm just [ __ ] i'm absolutely
fine but but but by the same token uh
you know i remember when i did my show
or it was called orwell that ends well
at edinburgh in 2018. he it was very
successful i sold lots of tickets
audiences loved it it went great i got a
mixture of very good reviews also the
people who are politically against that
gave me bad reviews but it was a good
show i can say that right and i remember
talking to a an older more experienced
comedian who who who's a friend uh and
he uh one i had two of them sitting at
the same table and one of them said look
i think you're going to get nominated
for the award and the other one went
what are you talking about he's like
he's lucky he's not going to get
assassinated right why was my show bad
was it unfunny no it's because it had
the wrong politics i was saying freedom
of speech is important
and i was talking about people like
chelsea russell who was a teenager who
got arrested and given a hate speech uh
prosecution and a criminal record
because she posted the lyrics of a rap
song on her instagram right i was
talking about people like that i was
talking about the fact that over 3 000
people a year in this country get
arrested for saying the wrong thing
that's the wrong politics now apparently
right yeah and
just to add to constantine's point the
quote from nika burns
is
i'm looking forward to the next
generation of work comedians deciding
what is and what isn't acceptable
yeah yeah i mean what would billy
connolly have said about this yeah get
to [ __ ]
in three months yeah
what was the incident that you had been
asked to sign a contract
can you tell us about that yeah so that
was what the show that i just talked
about was based around what happened was
i was performing at top secret which is
one of the best comedy clubs in london
and as i was outside a guy came up to me
he said oh i loved jose would you come
and perform at our charity night to help
us raise money for unicef or some other
charity i can't remember now the details
and i was like okay i'll happily donate
my time to help you raise raises money
and i forgot all about it uh and a few
weeks later i got an email from someone
else saying you said you'd be happy to
perform here's a contract
that we'd like you to sign and the
contract was called the behavioral
agreement form
and it said that uh by signing this
you're agreeing to a zero tolerance
policy on the following things racism
sexism classism ageism ableism
homophobia biphobia transfer by
xenophobe islamophobia anti-religion
anti-atheism and also said that all
jokes must be respectful and kind
[Laughter]
that's
that is funny right
and i and all i i turned it down and i
just said on my twitter which was like i
had like 800 followers or something
stupid at the time
i said you know this i got offered this
contract
for comedy this is i can't remember as i
either said this is disgusting or makes
me puke or whatever uh and
uh
it became a viral story this was uh the
second biggest story on the bbc news
website on the day that theresa may was
nearly removed from office by her own
party
right so it obviously something
resonated with the public and this is
why whenever we talk about this i always
bring it back to it's not just a couple
of whiny comedians the reason that went
viral and the reason people really cared
about it and responded to it was that
they feel this thing in their own lives
that they're constantly walking around
like they've signed the contract
not to make the wrong joke and not to
say the wrong thing a lot of people feel
that way now
and you know to me that was symbolic of
how society has changed in recent years
francis you mentioned about
cancer culture being brought in by a
very vocal minority
do you think a vocal minority can have
that power especially if the
comedians don't have that power we're
talking about if it had that power it
would have been banned by now how come
this vocal minority have got the power
to change your whole society because
what they have is they they have a
it's the ones who shout the loudest are
the ones that are heard
so people think that twitter is a far
bigger deal than it is
so 12 of the british population are on
twitter but therefore there is a storm
on tw uh twitter for whatever reason
then people get very anxious they get
very worried companies worry about their
public profiles they don't want to
associate with someone who is racist
sexist and whatever else also i'll give
you another example um i used to gig six
nights a week some of the biggest clubs
in london
and i used to mc a lot for them so i had
a lot of relationship with you know the
clubs and you know the bookers and
whatever else
and i and these are big clubs these are
clubs with seats of 250 300 seats
filling their their rooms six nights a
week pre-pandemic and i remember saying
to them
what's the situation been like with
complaints and each and every single one
of them has said that complaints have
been have skyrocketed
as a result now have people change the
vast majority of people don't care the
vast majority of people are very
reasonable they'll go and watch comedy
if something's not funny they'll be like
i just don't find it funny or he wasn't
very good she wasn't great or whatever
else but there is a small
entitled minority who will then go and
make a complaint
and every time they make a complaint
they make life difficult for the booker
the booker will then think
you know what do i really want to book
this comedian when there's so many
comedians out there who can come and
entertain my club and they're not going
to transgress they're not going to
offend they're not going to do this and
that and as a result what what is
acceptable to talk about on stage the
overton window narrows as a result and
you've seen it and now they've started
to go off the podcast there was a
podcast recently you know made jokes
about disabled people and then a
disabled charity got involved and the
comedians had to you know had to come
and then start and then apologize for it
and my question is i have a mother who's
disabled severely disabled right
how is a disabled charity getting
offended by a joke on a podcast helping
my mum shouldn't that charity instead of
listening to the podcast maybe think to
themselves hang on it's a global
pandemic disabled people now more
isolated than ever what can we do to
help these people and put support
structures in place in order that they
can live their lives to the fullest
estate and give them as much support as
possible but they don't do that you know
why because that's difficult that's not
going to go on our headlines what will
garner headlines is getting offended by
joke on a podcast yeah because it's easy
why are the vocal minority
doing this what would be the impetus to
shut people up well it's funny because
before we started the interview we were
talking about jordan peterson and
lobsters right it's all about social
signaling
it's all about saying i'm a good person
look at me look how virtuous i am i
voted remaining i voted as we joked
about earlier i'm a good person right
i have the right opinions i'm going
after the people that need to be going
to be gone after and it's incredible to
me how many times we've seen it in
comedy over the last 10 years where the
people who are
the most i'm a male feminist i'm this
i'm that they're the ones that end up
being outed as being predators of one
kind or another because they're all
signaling stuff to cover up for [ __ ]
instead of actually making a
contribution to people's lives in a
positive way
it's you know a good mate of mine is an
accountant and she always sits me down
and talks me about how she does the
books of left-wing does he accounts for
left-wing journalists and they're always
the ones that mung the most about the
tax that they pay and she's alright but
you're left-wing surely you understand
that your taxes
then go to fun public you know
so
people love to virtue signal they love
to display how good people they are
because a lot of the time
it's to compensate for the fact that
actually
behind closed doors they're not all that
because here's the reality karen none of
us are perfect we're all broken we're
all human we all do and say things that
we're not proud of yeah and the reality
is this perfect virtuous image that
these people try and create it's just an
image we're all human and that's the
thing they're denying their own humanity
because what they're doing is they're
denying the ability to transgress but
they're also denying the ability
to be forgiven
and to for redemption
and that's the real point of this i got
i almost went to like
end with a hymn
because that's i totally agree with that
and that's just spot on
do you find anything vanilla funny is
there something that you've watched
that's completely
uh absent of anything that smacks of
offense and you're rolling on the floor
laughing yeah of course look at michael
mcintyre yeah look at mike look
the most widely appealing comedy will
always be vanilla to some extent right
it will be about the day-to-day things
of people's lives and michael mcintyre a
lot of people in the comedy world like
to slag him off mainly because they're
just not as good as him right michael
mcintyre is one of the best comedians
yeah in this country why because he can
make people laugh
about anything right and you don't need
to be offensive
neither francis or i were particularly
offensive comics in terms of the
material that was one of the reasons it
was kind of odd for us to be feeling
these things happening there's loads of
stuff and uh you know we neither of us
would be like oh yeah all this all this
stuff that you now see all of it is
terrible all of it is crap we don't
think of it in in those ways but at the
same time you do see things becoming
diluted and there's it's like a lack of
flavor in your food it's the same it's
bland and a lot of it is boring not all
of it some of it is brilliant but
overall the standards have slipped in my
opinion in the last 10 years and you can
see it in audience numbers the audience
numbers for bbc comedy itv like all the
different tv channels are going through
the floor and that's partly because of
the impact of netflix and technology but
it's partly because of quality as well
it completely is and you go you know
vanilla i mean i wouldn't really
describe him as vanilla i'd describe him
as mainstream one of my all-time
favorite comics is mickey flanagan
you know my you know my girlfriend's
american and she was saying you know
like american comedy is better than
british comedy namely one british
comedian who's really naturally funny
and i played her you know mickey
flanagan and we sat there and we just
laughed like drains watching it he's a
phenomenal comedian and i'll tell you
what a bloody lover cat meme
i was i was showing you before the
before you turned up we were i was
sharing a couple of cat memes i love
them humor the thing that i love about
humor is that it's so incredibly broad
you can be silly you can be political
you can be satirical you can be
offensive transgressive you can be
observational
it
it can all be brilliant to put it very
simply
karen people on our side of the argument
are saying
let's have freedom let's let people make
the jokes that they want to make and let
the audience decide
what they want to see we are not trying
to shut anyone down we're not trying to
cancel vanilla comedians or progressive
comedians or woke comedians let them do
their jokes let them do whatever they
want right but let everyone else do the
jokes that they want to and then let's
see who who likes what surely we can all
get behind the idea that having more
choice about the sort of comedy that we
watch and listen to
is a good thing absolutely it's not
people come to me and just go oh you
must hate hannah gatsby i'm like why
what what have you what's happening with
hannah garcia oh so hannah gadsby did a
show called nanette yeah yeah and then
they go don't you think that this is i'm
like no i think it's great that she's
got a career for herself i think it's
brilliant that she can do the albert
hall and do her comedy to her fans more
power to her now would we go and watch
that is a different thing i have watched
the net i didn't particularly think it
was a good show but but that's my
opinion right i could be completely
wrong i'm wrong all the time do you know
what i mean and i don't want people
whose comedy i don't like to be shut
down that's the difference between me
and the other side of this debate yeah
but why were you thinking why were your
friends thinking that you wouldn't like
it don't what did they say you don't you
think this is what was the blank uh so
like don't i mean don't you think this
is basically crap and what whatever else
and you know the
there are people who project
what they think i'm thinking okay and
because i'm on a particular side of an
argument oh well you must think this but
there's also there's a lot of
polarization that's happening so and
this is an issue for us and you know our
producer anton actually put this much
better than either of us ever have he
said what we do on the show is we hold
the line and sometimes we're on this
side of the line and sometimes we're on
that side of the line and and it is true
that people who are often presenting
themselves as pro-freedom and
anti-cancer culture will very happily
cancel people who have the wrong opinion
for them right there's an inconsistency
on both sides of this argument and we
don't buy into either of those sides we
are saying let's not cancel each other
let's listen to each other let's have a
bit of forgiveness let's give each other
the benefit of the doubt if you made a
joke that i didn't like did you make
that joke because you're evil and you
hate russians or you hate jews or you
hate whatever or is it just because you
were trying to make a joke and it didn't
quite work out and we can just carry on
as mates yeah and that doesn't need to
be under the guise of humor you know
you're gonna
that's gonna bleed out of people if it's
in them whether they're doing it as a
joke or not what does cancer culture as
a myth mean
well the joke on the poster is is joseph
stalin who famously cancelled quite a
few people about 50 million people in my
country uh and we just thought it kind
of it shows you what's happening in
society now because the very people who
are running around organizing
cancellations of other people they are
the same people who then say that cancel
culture as a myth and doesn't exist and
to me that's a perfect illustration
joseph stalin who who murdered millions
of people and denied
that any of that was happening it's kind
of the same process on a different way
in a different level where people are
canceling people forcing them to lose
their careers attacking them being
vicious to them at the same time as
pretending that they're good people who
are not doing anything wrong
is there anyone who's been cancelled
publicly
that it's helped their career
probably probably you know i don't think
any on the top of my head no no it's
true you're right what happens is
it depends on what you do as the person
who's being cancelled right uh and also
depends on what you're being cancelled
for i mean if you're being canceled for
genuinely doing something wrong
then that's different to being canceled
for something you haven't done wrong you
know yeah uh that's a big difference
because you know in this by the same
token of when we talk about forgiveness
you can't forgive someone who doubles
down on
something wrong that they've done right
forgiveness requires a degree of
contrition you know so there will be
people absolutely who who who've been
cancelled and have moved
up as a result um
and
to me that's the right decision if
you're being canceled for something you
haven't done when you've done nothing
wrong of course you should run with it
of course you should make hay while that
is happening of course you should what
should you lie down and just give up
because some people decided you need to
be destroyed um do you think some people
are trying to get cancelled on purpose
to get more publicity
who's it lee hust some of the stuff that
he's putting out you just think what are
you trying to do
is like a multi-millionaire why does he
need to get canceled i think he's just
he just likes rubbing people up the
wrong way i think look i'm sure
hypothetically speaking there is someone
somewhere that's trying to get cancelled
to get attention uh but i think that
argument is often overused like when i
turned down that contract i turned it
down because i come from a family in
russia where almost all of my
grandparents and great-grandparents were
put in the gulag for having the wrong
opinion so to me the idea that i now in
britain in 2021 and people are telling
me what i can and can't say that's
abhorrent to me and that's why i'm
understand but a lot of people said that
i did it for the attention when i
tweeted it to 800 people right and i had
no if i could make stories go viral
there'd be a story about me saying every
[ __ ] day right do you know what i
mean yeah yeah yeah
where do you guys go next with your
comedy in in this
era
right well
we have a lot of very very big plans we
really at the moment
we're focusing on doing our interviews
we've started to branch into live shows
we're going to see what happens with the
issue of vaccine passport so that's been
another
completely coming out blindsided us
however we also want to go into writing
satirical writing sketch because there's
a lot a lot of topics that mainstream
particularly bbc won't touch and if they
do touch they'll only touch on it from a
particular angle so we're going to be
looking to
let's look at the flip side let's look
at what other people actually think
and tackling these subjects and also
trying to make a point with them because
that's to me the art of great comedy is
where you make someone laugh and you go
well what have you thought about this
not telling them what to think that's
very very different but going have you
thought about this other way of looking
at it yeah
and that to me is the art of great
comedy and really we want to be moving
into that as well but
that also comes when the show gets
bigger when we have more bandwidth when
we have more money and then you have
more the more that you can invest in
these particular types of projects
are you frightened
of repercussions or being recognized and
people abusing you no no no uh the truth
is as as you know the point that we've
made we
to a large extent made ourselves pariahs
in the comedy industry knowingly
knowingly we lessen you yeah well when
when we sat down to start the show
i said to francis
you're going to get attacked by
comedians people are going to call you
evil they're going to say your right
wing when you're not they're going to
call you a nazi you're going to lose
opportunities
and he didn't believe me
well
he now he does right but at the same
time look at where we're sitting yeah
we've been rewarded for for what we've
done so we have absolutely no fear
comedy people can't cancel us right the
only people we are answerable to is our
audience right and our audience are from
all over the political spectrum we have
mumsnet feminists who watch our show and
people on the right and people on the
left and people in the middle and a lot
of people in comedy who will never say
they watch the show but they do right
and they will message us privately why
would people in comedy not admit to
watching you because they know the
industry they're in they know that if
they admit to watching us they're going
to get cancelled a mate of mine and
they're a great comedian and i've
deliberately hid their agenda as their
gender as they're a woman yeah hey
and uh this person not necessarily uh
this person said
i love your show i could never admit it
publicly because i'd get cancelled and
this person is on the point of
doing you know breaking through
and to be honest
they've made the correct decision they
have really they've made the absolutely
correct if you want a mainstream career
don't admit to having any wrong opinions
that's the society yeah do you think
that walkness is just a fashion and the
ass is going to fall out yeah you know
everything is cyclical and we'll come
back into the comedy of offense
now
i mean event i'm not saying wokeness is
here forever but wokeness in many ways
for for all our distaste and
disagreement with with its central
tenants
is based on some value valid concerns
what are they well if you have a society
in which young people have no chance of
ever accumulating capital they they
don't have access to the housing market
they're completely alienated from it by
and large how are you going to expect
them to buy into the system how are you
going to expect people who who don't
have capital to be capitalist right and
if you want you know people
can we argue with conservatives about
this all the time as well i often say to
conservatives how are you expecting
young people to become traditionalists
and conservatives well they have nothing
to conserve
they don't have anywhere to live so they
can't get married so they can't start a
family which are the things that will
make you settle down and look after your
community and think more long-term about
things and be a bit more grounded and
you start paying tax and you kind of
realize things aren't as simple as just
go and give me more free stuff how is
that going to happen if people that
can't find a place to live they can't
get married they can't have kids how is
that going to happen do we know live in
a society at the moment that just gives
you free stuff anyway well that's what
we've turned into yeah you know and
and that's another point you know we
kind of now live in a society where
everyone's seeing at home they're
getting a load of free stuff
and
people seem fine with it and you can't
blame them i never blame people for
taking free stuff that they offered it's
the logical choice for you as an
individual to do that you cannot blame
people for doing that but the truth is
unless we give people the opportunity to
do well for themselves they will never
adopt the mentality of can do go get et
cetera that will never happen so to me
the idea that some people think that the
solution is you know we go conservative
about this is complete nonsense you've
got to fix the housing crisis you've got
to get people opportunity to advance in
their lives otherwise all the social
[ __ ] that comes from that is never going
away yeah
is there any topic that would be off
limits to you in comedy that you think
you know what even if that's the
greatest joke ever written
that's going to hurt people
no no because if it's the greatest joke
ever written
then it's going to be undeniably
brilliantly funny so there have been
many a time where you've probably
watched the comedian go i don't really
agree with that joke but it's brilliant
number one and it's made you laugh
and then number two it's a joke
it's not meant to be taken seriously
it's not about topics it's about the
angle of approach yeah right you can
make a deeply offensive joke about a
deeply inoffensive subject and vice
versa
what about the acts and
time plus tragedy equals comedy
or does there need to be time before we
can speak about something or
is it is that what makes it so
i can't believe he said that comedy is
that it's just happened we'll look at
one of the greats john rivers when her
husband committed suicide i think it was
six days
later or five days later she was making
jokes about it and she said
people were saying to how can you do
that your but your your husband has just
died and she went this is how i cope
i cope with laughing
that is what we do as human beings we
all know that we're doomed we all know
that we're gonna die we all know that
we're fragile [ __ ] hell may keep it
light
exactly but yeah we make jokes
absolutely to make the darkness more
bearable totally well i do and that's
exactly you know what is there's an old
saying what is comedy but making the
unbearable bearable so of course and you
think who's got the darkest sense of
humor medics
police officers firefighters because
they see the real dances of life
but there was john rivers now making a
joke about something that had happened
to herself and therefore that gives her
permission yeah but the fact that her
her husband died her husband had a
daughter
he had brothers you know he probably had
obviously he had surrounding family yeah
anybody else that's lost somebody to
suicide yeah yeah yeah it just
yeah you know
that's to me
that's how we cope
with all the things that happen we just
do
hey constantine do you love trigonometry
of course incredible interviews
hilarious live streams hard-hitting
satire plus my handsome jawline whatever
takes away from your hairline but if you
do love trigonometry and you want to
support us there's only one place to do
that and that's on locals yes locals is
a brilliant platform that has been
incredibly supportive to our show and
other problematic creators the great
thing about locals is that it's a
community for people who love
trigonometry that's right it's a place
for you to hang out with like-minded
people share thoughts memes and discuss
the show you can enjoy it for free but
it also gives you the option of
supporting us for as little as seven
dollars a month and if you want to give
more you can we have incredible rewards
for our higher tier supporters as well
we've got everything from mugs monthly
group calls and one on two chats with me
and kcat get in join our community by
hitting the link in the description and
the pin comment below see you there guys
so yesterday i went to television and
media operations uh
bbc
we watched sketches some of my sketches
that were no cancelled uh or edited of
the you know an extra piece
one of them was about
an old woman who was looking after her
grandson in her house and he they looked
there was a chest in the corner the
grandson asked what was in the chest he
was about seven
and the old woman took him to show him
it was a chest that your grandfather
brought back from singapore
and when it opened up this funky music
come out and dry ice and a pole and
there was a pole dancer in it and you
know so the kid's looking sort of
actually i don't know if he looked
shocked he might have been intrigued is
that right for me to say that [ __ ]
hell anyway and the kids looking at it
and the grannies watching quite
whimsically saying you know your
grandfather was awful for under that
chest while this poor dancer dances so
that's been cut for child safety
what do you think about that
child safety yeah because children yeah
sexual
sexualization
i mean there's plenty of sexualization
of children going on i don't think
that's the worst culprit right there do
you
to me that is a corporation that is an
organization protecting its back
because they they're leaving themselves
open to charges of
you know
it's a child it's a safeguarding issue
but also isn't that an issue that's
solved by advisory ratings like this is
a suitable for people over the age of
whatever like if you want to protect
children why do you have to cancel a bit
or remove a bit can't you just say this
show is only suitable for people over 16
or with parental guidance or whatever
yeah the thing is if it's to protect the
child actors
the actors have already done the same
so how are you protecting them from
something that's already happened to
them
that makes no sense it's all about
signaling and this is what the point
we're trying to get across to you this
is about the organization trying to look
virtuous oh look at this we've done
everything the actors have already done
the scene they've already been quote and
quite traumatized or whatever the word
is right you're not fixing anything when
it comes to that all you're doing is
trying to signal to other people how
good and progressive and virtuous you
are so what's happening there and it's
also as well we live in an era where
every kid and as a former teacher you
know i've seen in my own eyes gets given
a smartphone if you get if you give your
child a smartphone at the age of 10
they're about three clicks away from
accessing the hardest of the hardcore
pornography too yeah
so the reality is that you're protecting
from what a woman
dancing suggestively in a bikini is far
more wholesome than all the multitude of
pornography sites that exist currently
on the internet do we still have a duty
of care whether whether we're seen to be
doing it or know it be seen to be doing
it do we still have a duty of care to
try and protect the kids from seeing
that
i mean
it was already been short
but like we said advisory ratings pg or
15 or 16 or whatever it is what about
the edits that have been done in faulty
towers for
racist views
how does that change anything but here's
the thing you know
society changes
that is a reflection of society in the
1970s are we just going to pretend it
didn't happen are we just going to put
our fingers in our ears and go la la la
no that's how society was and in many
ways we should be giving ourselves a
little pout on the back going we don't
behave like that anymore you wouldn't
want to say that anymore that's fine
isn't it but as the if that episode of
40 towers went out in its entirety and
used those words
is that no given
racists license to use them because
they've seen it on the bbc come on look
this is all this is all a bunch of crap
this whole argument and i don't mean
this person no no
this is all a bunch of obsession about
racism that as i said to you before we
started britain is not a racist country
there is a handful of idiots who go and
send
you know stupid messages to footballers
and whatever they're a tiny tiny
minority the idea that some racist or
rather take it like this what someone
who wasn't racist watched something on
the bbc and now they became racist
because they saw john cleese
come on you know it says this a few
years ago when i was in the edmond
professional 2014. i looked jewish right
there was a group of uh scottish
football fans behind me in edinburgh and
they sang the words behind me i'd rather
be a [ __ ] than a jew right
okay it's all for it's abhorrent i
didn't particularly like it when it was
happened does it reflect scotland as a
whole yes but anyway
you know but of course it doesn't but
the idea that somehow those group were
all very liberal and tolerant they sat
down in front of liberal britain and
went hang on a second boyce let's go
i've got a few ideas here
i just find it yeah but we wouldn't be
making little britain now should we be
i don't have a problem with little
britain
no i don't have a problem at all i
thought it was hilarious yeah
you know it's
the idea that
see just this is a problem i have with
quite a lot of people on the left is
they feel we need to molly color people
we need to protect them and it's also
paternalistic and dare i say incredibly
patronizing because they think people
are stupid and if they think people are
stupid they're incapable of thinking for
themselves
most people realize when you watch
comedy that it's comedy it's ridiculous
it's a joke
people don't go and watch an arnold
schwarzenegger film and then think he
can take out 60 men with a flamethrower
no that's it
i agree
i agree
but don't show that
we will on our show yeah you can yeah
like you can because i do agree and uh
and i don't know what to do with it
i'm frightened of agreeing let me ask
you though you're a gay woman grew up in
scotland right i don't imagine that was
always easy right but i imagined that
your experience has made you tougher
made you able to deal with stuff made
you able to write comedy all of the it
made you who you are
right yeah so why why would we molly
coddle everyone and protect them from
everything i experienced racism as a kid
i don't particularly like i'm not saying
it's necessary to develop into a fully
fledged human being but would i want to
be locked in a room just so no one's
racist to me but if i had the choice of
you know creating something from my
trauma yeah
or no trauma i'll take no trauma sure
yeah but is that realistic though that's
the question right how much damage do
you have to do to everything else just
to get everyone no one to ever say the
wrong thing ever again what do you have
to do you have to put everybody in
prison then you might be able to do we
want to do that i don't think so right
that's the thing but you're afraid you
were saying why are you afraid i'm
afraid of ostracization i'm afraid of
judgment i'm afraid of violence
i'm afraid because i'm recognized as
well that if someone watches no what's
up and you can put this up because it's
true that if someone watches your stuff
and sees me saying this or some of the
things that i've said they'll jump on
that and say did you hear what camden
bar said and that will blow up into
something and i kind of got your tesco
so i'm afraid of that so so that's why
i'm asking you you know yeah yeah of
course but see that i totally get that
but then
take a step back and think that you're
not carrying them but you're someone
watching that
the fact that you feel that way
what does that tell you about the
society that we live in
but is that in it i felt that fear when
i was in the 70s
saying the wrong thing yeah it would
have just been a different wrong thing
what was it
well i don't know you know i don't like
your hair you know
whatever the wrong thing is i don't
think matters it's the fear that's
attached to saying the wrong thing
surely because whatever it is that you
put at the tribe
yeah yeah that's the thing do you know
what as somebody who has been kicked out
of the tribe it's incredibly painful
you're right in many ways to fear it
because
when you go through that process
it's an incredibly lonely feeling i'm
glad where i am i'm happy i've done what
i've done i wouldn't change it are you
talking about in the last 18 months in
the last 18 months
but the process of ostracization is
difficult we're tribal
we
are built to be in a tribe to be
accepted to be part of the group to be
ostracized from the group
it's painful and when you say you fear
it it's a very rational thing to fear
but but then the point comes with this
what is more important to you is it to
be accepted
or is it to have integrity
those are that's the question every day
of the week it would be to be accepted
and that but that but that and i'm i'm
i'm embarrassed to say that and yeah
it's the truth so let me just state it
and i'm seeing every day a week and
that's no that's not 100 true francis
but the the draw to integrity is taken
away by the threat of violence
whether it's outwardly or in my mind and
violence may be strong but i haven't
experienced extreme homophobia and and
having been ostracized through that
right then it's that
muscle memory that's like ah
i'm not gonna go through that again i've
had enough trauma to make comedy
i from deny that's that's what i'm going
through yeah and that's fair enough and
that's why we never ever say to people
this is what you must do and we never
say to people you're wrong for not
speaking the truth or whatever
everybody's got to make their own
decisions uh but to me
the fact that you fear
whatever you fear as a result of
speaking your mind in the same way that
you feared homophobes attacking you in
the street to me that tells me something
about the society that we live in i
agree yeah yeah and there's also a
question if you fear it so much then why
are you here why are you doing this
documentary well exactly because the
at the core the the fears and the mind
the the the core of me is within the
pull to integrity as
and i i'm
obviously i'm consciously trying to work
against that but i can't not because
it's intrinsic
and so probably that's why i'm here and
even i can feel the difference between
the floor conversation that we had when
we come in and how i'm i'm acting now
that i'm being recorded i feel it and i
don't like it
but i
feel the results and i know that it may
be edited differently for the bbc and
you may put this
exactly as it is and so i'm every word
that's coming out there's a my meg
doesn't look like careful bank but watch
redirect
and i'm trying to work against that then
this is this is you know my level of
courage at the moment is being able even
just admitting that and i'm sure
hopefully if anybody's watching this in
trigonometry and i'm not trying to do a
rallying caller anything but they're
like
i know
i know what am i going to do about that
and what's the risk to me trying to live
with integrity but let me tell you
something as well and this is something
that people don't talk about enough
people think that courage is this
mystical thing courage is a muscle yeah
the more you work on it the more you
build it the more you say what you think
the more you stand up for what you
believe
the stronger it gets
totally
absolutely and this is another
significant step for you
to come out and just to say this is what
i think i'm what i believe and you know
as somebody who uh who loves musical
theater is that famous song life ain't
worth a damn until you can say i am what
i am oh yeah i mean don't worry because
you had me it's somebody that loves
musical theater
are you talking with me oh my god you're
talking about you
oh we are one
particle um
so oh god um
so i'll ask you the question this time
guys what is a society are we not
talking about that we should be talking
about i mean there's one thing that some
people are talking about but i think not
enough
people understand what's happened in the
last 18 months to people's brains we've
just interviewed released an interview
with someone who talked about how the
government weaponized
behavioral science to brainwash people
and scare people into being unduly
afraid of covered now let's be very
clear covet is a deadly disease which is
dangerous to many people no one's
denying that and some of the measures
that were taken to protect people were
absolutely necessary and if people are
vulnerable whether because they're
elderly or whatever they should take the
vaccine blah blah you know all the
[ __ ] disclaimers that you want right
but the truth is
i am deeply uncomfortable
deeply uncomfortable as someone who
comes from a society which i've seen be
authoritarian at times with the
percentage of the british public who are
happy
who are happy look at some of the
polling numbers 20 percent of people in
this country
even if there is no covid would happily
accept a 10 pm curfew
really stay at home forever from 10 p.m
until the morning no covet
where's that statistic it's from one of
the recent polls look it up yeah yeah
yeah yeah i think it is it was an ipso
mario poll right uh apparently the
majority of people support vaccine
papers right this is literally paper and
bitter territory here you're talking
about segregating people based on their
medical status for a disease and you and
this is really just to force young
people to take the vaccine
to young people covert is less dangerous
than flu
right so you're forcing young people to
inject something into their body
that's newly created we don't know the
long-term effects of it right you're
doing that by threatening to take away
their rights which which are god-given
if you believe in god right it's like
saying well if you don't take the
vaccine we're gonna take your driving
license away what
how did that happen in 21st century
britain we're not we're not in soviet
russia here and no one seems to
understand that this is this is they've
crossed the line here
they have absolutely crossed the line
and i'm amazed the artists aren't coming
out against this comedians aren't coming
musicians because we're the ones that
are supposed to be like yeah free for
all you know do whatever no that [ __ ]
conformist to to to a level that i
cannot understand
yeah but aren't artists
comedians in it so that they can get
capital to so that they can buy any
capitalism so they can get the house and
they can get married and have the kids
or whatever that road is
therefore you either speak the truth you
come out against it
and give up your house or you keep your
head and do vanilla and have a nice
quiet life
there's room for enough people to do
either really yeah there's room there's
room for i'm not saying every single
comedian and every single artist and
whatever but there's got to be more
people than the ones that are speaking
out that could do yeah you know
and the fact that people aren't
shocked
and not shocked to the core
at the widespread acceptance of this
authoritarianism and this slippery slope
from one thing to another to another
i am incredible i'm just amazed that
that's the case yeah i'm amazed that
that's the case and for me it's the
latest bill that pretty patella is
trying to get through parliament
to make it
illegal for journalists to embarrass the
government punishable by up to 14 years
in jail so for instance those
journalists who handled the matt hancock
video of him getting it on with his
advisor
they would now be in jail and that that
is a story that is in the public
interest
that
the health minister was a hypocrite who
was breaking the regulations that he
implemented
on our country
but it's going to be made illegal for
journalists to break that story with 14
years
we don't know we don't know but they're
trying but that's why we're raising both
of these issues the same with vaccine
passports i don't think they're going to
go through but they're threatening
people
with taking away their rights so that
people take the vaccine that some young
people choose not to that's the [ __ ]
choice yeah it's a free society that's
where we are in 2021
we are facing
a real challenge to our civil liberties
by a government whose mask has slipped
and they're incredibly authoritarian and
we all of us left right center
woke anti-woke progress whatever you it
doesn't matter anymore the culture war
stuff i i still it's it's important but
this what we're talking about now
we need to be fighting this every single
person on this island tooth and nail
because once these liberties are gone
you ain't gonna get them back look at
look at what happened after 9 11.
look at what happened after some guy
took some shoes or a bottle of water
that he tried to use
are you are you able to go on on a plane
since without having your shoes checked
without having to
once the government takes the freedom
they're never giving it back never and
they are trying to cross several lines
here that are just not acceptable what
do you see down the line of that
if we don't stand up it's a slippery
slope it starts with
festivals
live events night clubs then they're
going to bring it in restaurants pubs
coffee shops and it will eventually end
with you having to take a vaccine i'm
not anti-vaxx neither is constantine i
am against a government coercing you
twisting your arm essentially forcing
you into injecting something into your
body
that is wrong and that is what the
government will do
these vaccine passports are id cards on
steroids
that will mean they can track every
single one of your movements you will
have to present it in a pharmacy in a
shop
that's where it's going to end up unless
you stand up now yeah what what about
the argument that that's already
happening if you've got an iphone
it's not untrue it's not untrue it's not
true but but the fact that the
government is doing it is different
because the government is far more
incompetent
than and so all of these databases are
going to get hacked the information is
going to leak people are going to find
out your personal medical details
they're going to blackmail you they're
going to dox you if you've got the wrong
opinion or whatever it's so you don't
want to trust me trust me you do not
want to open this pandora's box
i can get a nokia 3210 and that still
means that i can go and have absolutely
no you know i can still go to
glastonbury or whatever else
[ __ ] sake what's to be done we are
really hailing a hand cat stuff it is it
is
that's why courage is needed yeah
it's a muscle [ __ ] off for your
courageous
zombified in front of netflix with a
packet of cattle chips and
cows they're the best oh
draw the mouth but yes
and again i'll go for a walk around the
park as long as i'm in by 10. yep
yeah
you know this is how much your
government have taken the piss
they banned selling alcohol in scotland
and when i heard that i'm like are they
trolling you hmm
i don't know if that's
all bad
karen thanks so much for coming and
talking to us asking us a question it's
been a pleasure to meet you and all the
very best of luck with the documentary
likewise and thanks guys for for all
your honesty and your courage and if you
never see me again know that you were
wanted needed and loved thank you very
much
guys we will see you for another
terrific episode or live stream and they
always go out same time 7 p.m uk time 2
p.m eastern standard take care and see
you soon
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below